[Musique]
salut à tous il y a dix ans le 7
novembre 2008 jean luc mélenchon
quittait le parti socialiste pour fonder
le parti de gauche pour fêter ses 10 ans
entre guillemets je vous propose une
rétrospective des différentes stratégies
adoptées par mélenchon depuis cette date
ainsi qu'une analyse du fonctionnement
de la france a soumises
alors pourquoi se pencher sur le
fonctionnement de la france insoumise et
bien parce que souvent le fonctionnement
d'un parti en dit long sur l'état
d'esprit de ses chefs et sur la façon
dont qu'ils appréhendent le pouvoir et
tout d'abord commençons par la
rétrospective après avoir été militant
trotskiste dans sa jeunesse jean luc
mélenchon entre au parti socialiste dans
les années 70 où il gravira petit à
petit les échelons électif mais ce
membre de l'ailé gauche du parti restera
au second plan jusqu'en 2005
à ce moment lors du référendum sur le
traité constitutionnel européen
il appelle à voter et fait campagne pour
le non a contrario du parti qui lui
s'est positionné pour le oui suite à
cela il gagne en audience médiatique
mais est de plus en plus isolé au sein
du parti qu'il finira par quitter en
novembre 2008 au congrès de reims
ne supportant plus ce qu'ils considèrent
être une dérive sociale libérale avec
une poignée de fidèles
ils fondent dans la foule et le parti de
gauche de fait l'espace politique du pg
est réduit il doit cohabiter avec le pcf
et le npa alors en pleine construction
et fort d'une importante dynamiques
attirants pas mal de monde et dans
l'orientation n'est pas encore clair car
si aujourd'hui le nouveau parti
anticapitaliste a fait un retour aux
sources aux trotskistes lors de sa
création il ratisse large
et de fait le pg et le npa ont un temps
le même public à savoir des militants de
gauche en quête de radicalité mais pas
trop en fait lors de la création du pg
jean luc mélenchon utilise une méthode
qui sera ensuite une constante chez lui
s'inspirer de ce qui se fait à
l'étranger sur le moment et à l'époque à
la gauche de la gauche
on parle beaucoup de die linke un
nouveau parti allemand issu de la fusion
de l'ex parti communiste d'allemagne de
l'est et d'une fraction de la spd le
parti socialiste allemand jean luc
mélenchon espère que le pg sera la
composante socialiste de cet attelage il
va donc mettre en oeuvre cette stratégie
rouge rose en créant le front de gauche
il ne s'agit pas d'une fusion comme en
allemagne mais d'un cartel regroupant le
pcf le pg et quelques groupuscules cette
alliance sera testée aux européennes de
2010 avec un succès moyen puis c'est
l'élection présidentielle de 2012
mélenchon il porte les couleurs du front
de gauche et incarne selon ses propres
termes le bruit et la fureur
c'est un tribun aux discours violent et
radicale qui fait peur à une partie de
la gauche
il y obtient un score correct mais
décevant deux ans plus tard il va créer
le m5 r le mouvement pour la vème
république
inspiré du mcr de chavez laissant de
côté le parti de gauche qui se vide peu
à peu de ses militants le but du mcr est
de fédérer non plus sur la question
sociale purs et durs mais sur la
question démocratique comme chavez lors
de son élection en 1999
le mcr sera un échec et aura une
existence uniquement virtuelle 2014
c'est aussi l'année des élections
municipales à ce moment là le phénomène
longtemps dont on entend parler syriza
en grèce dirigée par alexis tsipras ce
conglomérat d'écolo et de sectes
marxiste léniniste refusant tout
compromis avec les socialistes grecs
le front de gauche dépose des listes
mais des tensions avec le pcf se font
jour sur la question des alliances
en effet le parti communiste favorise
des alliances avec le ps dans certaines
villes où l'élection de majorité de
gauche ne fait pas de doute cela crispé
jean luc mélenchon qui veut une
autonomie totale vis-à-vis des
socialistes à l'image de syriza en grèce
sans compromis avec le ps à qui il voue
désormais une haine viscérale au pg
aussi des tensions apparaissent là où
des militants locaux veulent faire des
alliances avec le parti socialiste
mais devant le refus catégorique de
mélenchon de faire des alliances avec
les socialistes certains démissionneront
le front de gauche réussira à faire
élire un maire grâce à une alliance
rouge rose vert à grenoble ce maire sera
portée aux nues comme étant un exemple
de la stratégie victorieuse de non
compromission à la syriza début 2015
syriza grâce à son chef alexis tsipras
ce remporte les élections en grèce jean
luc mélenchon jubile et puis si prace
encensé quelques mois auparavant doit
céder sur la question de la dette face
aux pressions des institutions
internationales à peine converti
mélenchon brune sa nouvelle idole qui
n'est plus maintenant qu'un traître à
ses yeux alors ils se tournent vers
podemos parties espagnoles créées en
2014 et dont le succès se profile à
l'horizon
mélenchon reprend le vocable de podemos
et commence à parler de caste
d'oligarchie deux peuples a laissé de
côté le clivage gauche droite au profit
du clivage au bas et comment celui même
à se pencher sur les thèses du populisme
de gauche de laclos et bouffe qui ont
inspiré les espagnols et puis en 2016
aux etats unis c'est l'apparition de
bernie sanders socialiste qui rattrape
clinton dans les sondages des primaires
démocrates
sanders fait une campagne très
centraliser fait d'initiatives locales
grâce à une plateforme internet
hélas après une demi douzaine d'années
d'errance tactique il va y avoir un
tournant majeur
jean luc mélenchon va mixer la stratégie
dite populiste de gauche dépôt demos et
l'organisation décentralisée de sanders
au passage il troque son habit de tribun
incarnation du bruit et de la fureur
pour la figure du vieux professeur
pédagogue que l'expérience a rendu sage
imitant en cela bernie sanders dont il
reprend aussi les codes visuels la
france insoumise nne et enfin jean luc
mélenchon semble avoir trouvé une forme
organisationnelle qui lui conviennent
avant de continuer sur l'analyse du
fonctionnement de la france est soumise
quelques remarques pendant toutes ces
années jean luc mélenchon s'est conduit
comme un autocrate et a dirigé ces
organisations quasiment seul avec un
noyau de dirigeants fidèles qu'il
connaît depuis longtemps
résultat ces organisations n'ont jamais
tenues et le pg par exemple est passé de
12 mille membres revendiqués à sa
fondation à deux à trois milles maximum
aujourd'hui la démocratie interne jamais
été le fort de jean-luc mélenchon et les
probables que si aujourd'hui la france
insoumise est une formule qui lui
convient
c'est pour de mauvaises raisons en effet
la france est soumise est une structure
extrêmement antidémocratique
la plupart des partis ont une forme
pyramidale via une continuité entre la
base et le sommet par le biais de postes
électifs interne et citoyens et selon
que l'on grimpe généralement petit à
petit c'est une forme de cursus honorum
pour reprendre un terme de la rome
antique la france insoumise ne
correspond pas à ce schéma
vous avez des groupes de base de taille
réduite douze personnes maximum qui sont
largement autonome quant à leur mode
d'action mais qui ne pèse en rien sur la
ligne stratégique du parti car il y a
peu de structures permettant d'interagir
avec le noyau dirigeant national le seul
lien qu'il ya entre les deux ce sont des
convention nationale réunie tous les six
mois au mieux et dont le mode de
désignation lui-même verrouille la
structure 60% sont tirés au sort parmi
la base et les 40% restants sont des
mandatés de commissions diverses et de
partis alliés
or le tirage au sort n'est pas
démocratique c'est une méthode qui a le
vent en poupe dans certains milieux
voulant repenser la démocratie mais
c'est probablement la pire des idées ce
système est inspiré de la démocratie
athénienne antique où certaines
fonctions publiques étaient tirés au
sort aujourd'hui quand on pense tirage
au sort on part du principe que le
hasard tranchera dans la grèce antique
le tirage au sort ne repose pas sur le
hasard sur une formule probabiliste mais
sur la volonté des dieux
du destin c'est extrêmement différents
de fait le tirage au sort aujourd'hui
s'apparente plus à une forme de sondage
on prend au pif une personne qui portera
un vote une opinion censés être
représentatifs de la masse militante
ces insoumis tirés au sort par
définition ne sont pas des délégués mais
un échantillon supposé représentatif de
plus le tirage au sort renforce sa
division eaux bas et assure la
suprématie d'une minorité regroupés
autour de jean luc mélenchon il ne
permet pas contrairement à l'élection de
délégués de voir apparaître des leaders
issus de la base par réélections
successives dans les instances internes
ce fonctionnement de fait crée de se
faire à la base une masse d'anonymes qui
n'ont aucune chance d'accéder à des
responsabilités et enroule une élite
politique très fort mais qui décide seul
des orientations nationales
ce noyau dirigeant constituait dès les
premières heures de la france insoumise
est extrêmement homogène
par exemple chez les vieux dirigeants
issus du ps cordière mélenchon
coquerelles et même les amène bloc
d'après une source militante ont tous un
passé trotskiste et la plupart étaient
lambertiste on a un entre soi avec des
références communes extrêmement fortes
et il doit être extrêmement compliqué de
s'insérer dans ce groupe dirigeant ce
groupe d'ailleurs entretient aussi
l'absence de démocratie et en est
conscient il faut dire que le flou dans
le fonctionnement à des avantages par
exemple officiellement jean luc
mélenchon n'est que le chef du groupe
parlementaire
et pourtant qui ne vois pas en lui le
chef de la france insoumise d'autant
plus qu'il se comporte comme tel dans le
mouvement anarchiste dont je suis issue
à la base ça porte un nom ça s'appelle
la tyrannie de l'absence de structure
dans une organisation quand vous n'avez
pas de structure de débat et de décision
démocratique quand le pouvoir n'est pas
encadré et bien tout se joue dans
l'informel est généralement dans ce cas
là et bien c'est celui qui gueule le
plus fort qui emporte le morceau
résultat des courses ce mode
d'organisation permet une autonomie du
noyau dirigeant par exemple on est passé
d'un populisme de gauche mais reposant
sur un discours ni gauche ni droite à
une alliance avec les déçus du ps sans
discussion nationale la france insoumise
reproduit le schéma social qu'elle
dénonce dans la société
vous avez la masse des 99% qui
travaillent et le 1 % qui dirait jeu
c'est une forme de leadership est le
meilleur moyen d'y entrer ce n'est pas
de partir de la base de la france
insoumise mais de passer par des moyens
détournés
les partis alliés regardez les députés
la plupart provient d'un parti où ils
ont grimpé en interne et bénéficie d'un
capital politique qu'ils y ont acquis au
total douze sons
on était encarté dans des partis de
gauche avant l'existence de la france
insoumise parfois de longue date
certains de ses députés ont suivi
mélenchon lors de la création du parti
de gauche
la plupart a donc un fort bagage
politique obtenu dans un parti classique
comme une entreprise qui recrute ses
cadres n'ont pas parmi ses employés de
base mais dans de grandes écoles la
france insoumise puise ses cadres non
pas dans son vivier militants mais dans
les écoles à cadres politiques que sont
les partis
au final le fonctionnement de la france
est soumise ressemble fortement à une
entreprise de la start up nation vous
avez à la base des collectifs de travail
éclaté à qui on vend des discours axé
sur l'autonomie d'action et le côté
participatif et inclusif et en fait à
côté de cela vous avez un noyau
dirigeant totalement autonome qui ne
rend de comptes à personne
et si ce fonctionnement plaît autant à
des militants de gauche c'est peut-être
qu'ils sont plus poreux à l'air du temps
néolibérale et managériale qui veulent
bien croire et c'est sur cette
conclusion qui va encore me permettre de
me faire des amis à la france insoumise
que cette vidéo se termine
s'il vous a plu n'hésitez pas à la
partager et moi je vous dis à la
prochaine
[Musique]